gêné tellement eu peu de compromis
chaque islamisme que j'ai été à
l'origine avec jean françois copé de la
loi sur l'interdiction de la burqa dans
l'espace public j'ai ensuite quand j'ai
été élu était élu président de région
fait voter une charte de la laïcité pour
que jamais dans ma région il ya un euro
de subvention qui al à une association
avec des ennemis de la réunion cela que
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs de le faire
mon nationale y est vous et le front
national à l'époque vous vous en faisiez
partie a refusé de vous défier cette
vallée ricard laïcité et valérie
pécresse mais je pouvais revenir sur un
sur sur un point on a on a eu 10 pour
vous marion maréchal et d'extrême droite
moi ce que je comprends je comprends que
madame maréchal veut elle veut que
l'extrême droite et la droite fusionnent
voilà et bien moi je lui dis non pour
moi il ya un cordon sanitaire c'est mon
lycée le général de gaulle l'a tracé
ensuite jacques chirac posées qu'on a un
cordon sanitaire entre la droite extrême
on n'est pas on n'a pas la même nature
mais elle ne m'a pas répondu sur la sq a
dit eric zemmour c'est parce que cela
lui fait d islam c'est la même chose moi
je lutte contre le totalitarisme
islamiste et géant lutte pied à pied
j'ai mis en place là encore toujours
dans ma région et je le ferai pour la
france des lanceurs dahleb d'alert dans
les clubs sportifs pour repérer les
signes de radicalisation et je vais
présenter une loi constitutionnelle aux
français pour permettre de lutter encore
plus contre l'islamisme donc est
notamment allé consulter des sites
jihadistes par exemple ce sera un délit
les terroristes islamistes qui sort de
prison ils auront des peines de sûreté
de rétention à leur sortie de prison
pour plus être un danger pour autrui et
puis je vais permettre dans cette loi
aussi que la radicalisation puisse être
une cause réelle et sérieuse de
licenciement dans la fonction publique
parce que et dans les entreprises parce
qu'elles en ont besoin je lui pose la
question il ya une question oui mais bon
concret concrètement au madame le père
mes émotions je fais non sa loge et moi
j'ai une question parce que vous dites
refusé d'avouer rappelé madame le pen
oui bon madame arracher un mot j'ai pas
de problème mais dans tous les cas les
deux me vont mais je m'appelle madame
maréchal samar civile une chose parce
que vous expliquer donc je suis pour
allier la droite et d'extrême droite
mais j'aimerais savoir du coup qu'est ce
que vous pensez du fait que votre propre
bras droit eric ciotti ou le chef de la
délégation et l'air au parlement
européen en l'occurrence françois xavier
bellamy ou d'autres sénateurs de type
etienne blanc ont expliqué que s'il y
avait un deuxième tour emmanuel macron
eric zemmour il voterait pour eric
zemmour sans hésitation donc je
comprends pas ce que ces gens sont
d'extrême droite et ce qui est sûrement
la compromission avec l'extrême droite
est ce que vous pourriez me répondre là
je ne veux pas vous vous êtes pour moi
vous êtes la division de l'extrême voilà
il ya l'extrême droite c'est marine le
pen et il y avoue qu' qui avait dit
lisez votre propre famille qui avait
quitté votre temps je crois en l'amour
c'est l'extrême droite mais ces
mouvements rivaux la fusion il veut que
la droite et l'extrême droite
décomplexée mon île au milieu de marine
le pen et demi il est complice de
l'extrême vote pas ce qui va y aviez va
finir par s'allier il va finir par voter
marine le pen met donc eric gil va voter
à tort alors eric zemmour va voter
marine le pen qui a tort
moi j'ai des alliés qui pensent pas
forcément tous comme moi voilà mais le
sujet
est pas le sujet ils sont pas
extrêmement ils sont de droite ils sont
avec moi et d'ailleurs c'est avec moi
qu'il travaille donc en conclusion nous
ne sommes pas d'extrême droite on a
avancé là dessus au mois